[Musique]
le carburant à l'huile de palme bientôt
bannis de l'union européenne nicolas
hulot le ministre français de la
transition écologique et solidaire a
autorisé l'ouverture d'une raffinerie
total dans le sud est de la france pour
y produire du carburant
l'entreprise utilisera de l'huile de
palme de quoi provoquer une levée de
boucliers de la part d'associations de
défense de la nature la culture de
l'huile de palme entraînant des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et de
la déforestation
nicolas hulot a donc tenu à rassurer en
déclarant sur europe 1 on est en train
de s'organiser en oeuvre au niveau
européen pour organiser la sortie de
l'huile de palme et donc sortir de ce
qu'on appelle la déforestation apportées
alors nicolas hulot dit il vrai l'union
européenne est elle réellement en train
de tourner le dos à l'huile de palme ce
qui est sûr c'est que le parlement
européen s'est prononcée en janvier
dernier en faveur d'une élimination
progressive de l'huile de palme sous la
forme de carburant d'ici 2021
cette proposition fait encore l'objet de
discussions
la commission européenne propose une
réglementation afin de mettre des
limites mais n'a pas approuvé la fin du
carburant à l'huile de palme le conseil
européen doit encore statuer la culture
de l'huile de palme et peu coûteuse et
facile à travailler pour l'industrie
certains états membres sont donc frileux
à l'idée de s'en passer
c'est le cas pour l'instant de l'espagne
et de l'italie les deux plus gros
producteurs d'oeufs bio diesel de palme
comme de nouveaux gouvernements viennent
d'arriver au pouvoir dans ces pays leurs
positions sur l'huile de palme n'est pas
encore connue quant à la france nicolas
hulot assure qu'elle aura une position
forte à bruxelles contre l' usage de
l'huile de palme dans les biocarburants
mais avec l'ouverture de cette
raffinerie la france envoie un signal
plutôt contraire
si on regarde les chiffres on voit que
l'union européenne ne semble pas aller
vers une sortie de l'huile de palme la
consommation totale d'huile de palme de
l'union a augmenté de 7% entre 2016 et
sur cette même période la production de
bio diesel de palme dans l'union a
augmenté de 13 5%
on l'a vu le débat est ouvert au niveau
européen mais on est encore bien loin
d'un accord sur une sortie de l'huile de
palme
ce que dit nicolas hulot est donc
contestable
[Musique]